saying that most of our ocean floor is
unmapped isn't entirely true we do have
maps created by satellites that do all
this fancy measuring of differences in
gravity caused by the ocean floor's
topography but the resolution of these
Maps isn't great these satellite maps
only show features larger than five
kilometers which is like huge meanwhile
our maps of friggin Mars have a
resolution of like six meters so what's
the benefit of having a detailed map of
our ocean for starters it's just
freaking cool but also the ocean is
hugely important to our survival aside
from providing me with delicious Seafood
it's also the largest carbon sink that
we have on our planet and it helps
regulate all sorts of different things
like I don't know global temperatures
might be important not to mention we'll
probably find new resources that we can
use which actually now that I think
about it could totally backfire because
humans kind of suck at finding resources
and not totally exploiting them beyond
the preparer that being said how do we
even begin to protect something that we
don't even know exists